I don't know I just feel like I'm uh
when you meet me it's very underwhelming
I should probably sell myself better
I say these things out loud
like when you meet me and it's like oh
hello I have a YouTube channel and like
when you go to a networking event
anywhere if you're in La you're [__]
you have to be like you have to say all
the incredible things you've done like
really fast in 20 seconds and but like
when I meet people I'm like yeah I have
a YouTube channel but now I could be
like yes I'm a Sunday Times New York
Times best-selling author if someone
tells me that I'm just gonna think
they're absolutely yeah Mr Dick
how should I introduce myself when I
meet people what do you say me yeah uh
often whales in it well uh where was his
most famous
was his most mediocre twitch streamer uh
also go with twitch now I just go online
personality which is an online so maybe
we don't show you an influencer I don't
know
say I say a general online personality
and they're like what does that mean I'm
like well if you know you know cycling
yeah I was like do you like auctions
what do you say get on say I talk about
anime for a living talk about anime that
kind of work yeah well I guess that
works what do you say I say I say anime
no I say CEO of a fashion brand CEO of a
fashion that's that's worse than
best-selling author
they're both just as pretentious fashion
brand nobody buys it
[__] CEO I'm the CEO of a broad Japan
industry crap isn't it that's what you
can say someone tells you they're a CEO
I immediately think you're an idiot
when people say it it's like it's if you
because most of you have to introduce
himself see you I feel like a lot of the
time
um well yeah they don't say the word see
yeah I don't know yeah unless they're
like really help themselves
someone that immedially says I'm a CEO
I'm like yeah of what yeah anything on
that yeah you might as well just feel
entrepreneur on your uh Twitter
yeah yeah I think people realize that
entrepreneur has a bad taste in a lot of
people's mouths yeah yeah
because CEO is now the big hot wood that
everyone it's like oh I know I'm just
really bad at saying myself because I
don't want to go too far that's a
British thing though isn't it yeah I
think it's a British we just don't we
just [__] and I go to La and the first
sentence is oh yeah hi I'm this I've
done this I've done this it is weird
when I talk to people and they're like
really proud about what they do yeah and
I'm like why are you proud why are you
proud I'm like hi I watch cartoons and
uh that's uh
in L.A everyone I spoke to was like yeah
I'm writing a script for a movie that
Steven Spielberg looked at once five
years ago and it's like oh wow great
yeah and like everyone really put like
pushes themselves yeah and in the UK I
feel like you just sound like a
douchebag if you say you've done
anything yeah yeah so it's kind of like
you could literally have like cured
cancer and they'd be like everyone like
I [__] off Barry right six what are you
[__] doing oh gosh mate that's why I
just I I [__] hate networking yeah
yeah it's like it's like speed dating
for your ego so you're like you go there
and you're just like let me inflate my
ego as much as possible and see all
these inflated egos well the most
important people often are the ones that
have to desperately be like I've done
this I've yeah good cancer and built a
rocket out of salmon and you're like
well yeah I when I'm a network even I
remember I was one at the UK years ago
five years six years ago yeah way
through the career and uh I was like oh
you know I do YouTube videos and he went
oh yeah
well I'm sort of looked past me and it's
just like ah [__] this yeah it sort of
just looks away and takes a flip and
they're looking past you they're trying
to find someone else to bounce off too
yeah I don't know what what can I what
can I call myself what can I say I think
being a YouTuber is fine yeah I think I
think it's getting selling author
YouTuber you can you can you can tack
that on top of no I think the
best-selling author will work against
the YouTuber title it'll come off as bad
yeah I think you should just mention
your YouTuber and then just mention like
it should naturally come up in
conversation you know because
best-selling author kind of gives the
vibe that you're doing I'm desperate
I want the title buy the book I am
desperate I'm desperate of course you
are whatever I've done nothing nothing I
mean boxed the chest boxes that's how
you can say you're like I'm a on I'm an
undefeated chess boxing champion
yeah there you go yeah there you go yeah
I don't know it's one of those things
and like even some people spot me around
Tokyo as happens quite a lot now
Victorious yeah you know somebody met me
I was out waiting outside of uh you
might have been Shibu station today and
so on you um you're born in Japan I went
I think so it's like even I like trying
to be humble because you're gonna be
like yeah of course I [__] amate yeah
even that that British like weird humble
networking thing yeah that extends to
like people run into me yeah you know
I'm like oh I think I'm I think I'm
abroad in Japan yeah whenever whenever
someone comes out to me they're like are
you the anime man I'm just like no
and then but then sometimes I guess they
don't they don't see the the irony in it
so I remember this one dude was just
like are you the anime man and I was
like no and he's like oh okay he just
walked off I felt so bad I'm like no no
I'm just kidding I'm scared I I did that
literally two weeks ago yeah
I'm uh no and then he went he sort of
looked like he'd broken he was like
before
stood there for a moment and I was like
I was like this guy looks like he's
gonna die uh no idea there's more fans
recognizing you and no honestly it's not
so much being approached it's how you
approach me yeah you go Chris I brought
your book up like you're my best friend
basically if they've uh spent money
then uh they're your best [__] friend
you've bought the everyone Japan book
and you've tangible proof you know I'll
be nicer than someone if they're like oh
I've subbed you on Twitch so I'm like oh
you actually [__] watch my stuff yeah
yeah like a lot of people see it and
they're like I don't really know but I
think you're famous also yeah I think if
people approach me and they they clearly
know who I am then that's fine it's cool
like it's good right you feel like
you're watching or you're meeting a
villa yeah there are times when people
are like you're that YouTube guy right
like I was at like squeegee fish market
for years ago someone came over you're
like a YouTuber you're a Dave in Japan I
was like damn [__] no no I'm not and I
think like but I've had people go you're
like famous for something I was with you
a few months ago having a barbecue or
something
so we just yeah we went to this one spot
and I I was like a it's like a what was
it called it was in um one of the one of
the Sukiyaki places yeah and we sit down
it's going pretty well for the first
like 10 minutes and we're just chatting
and it is roasting though it was
unbelievably hot in that restaurant let
me just turned the AC on and a group of
four white guys sit down and there's
always I think that moment I think in
our heads where we're like we did look
each other
yeah there's a lot of you know if you're
if you're an English-speaking tourist
odds are you've probably watched chances
of videos I'm gonna take this off in
case
um and so we kind of thought I wonder
and then it was very obvious pretty
quickly that at least two of them of the
four group had recognized yeah yeah and
then it became really awkward because
the two of them were trying to talk
about it and explain to the other two
and then this one other one of those his
friends was just so annoying he goes
really loudly in this restaurant he was
like
man they're just YouTubers man they're
not they're real people like really
maybe look to you I think he has a
podcast or something yeah yeah he was
like yeah right but like they were
literally like it's like this distance
it was just like we saw went yeah
stalkered for us because we're like yeah
just really came off as rude yeah I was
um you know I I don't mind it but I was
out with I was surfing with um Felix
right right that's the thing one one the
last times before uh his son was born
and um there was two people like a two
for a foreign couple basically like
swimming in the sea nearby and you could
tell they kind of recognized him and
were sort of lingering there and we got
out they they got out and we got out
shortly after a drink and without saying
anything like oh my God Felix what are
you doing here all that man I've loved
the videos they just they just charged
everyone can we have a photo and like
Phoenix was like no and like and like I
was like fair enough you know because
like he didn't say anything I think his
policies just don't take photos yeah I
think a good point because like when
you're that famous yeah it's gonna
happen you're gonna get mobbed but like
I that's sort of interaction I hate
people come over this I need to get a
photo he didn't say anything yeah
there's no like conversation there's no
conversation there you know that and
it's like and it's like and you don't
know whether they're like you know like
they actually really like your content
or they just recognized you from the
internet so yeah I got the impression
that maybe they just recognize it yeah
yeah yeah
you have a moment where you're just like
I don't know if you see me as just like
an object you know where it's just like
hey I get you watch my stuff but you
know yeah we are we are human beings
start a conversation with me yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you're gonna come up yeah
that's the determining fact so if you
ever run into us start a conversation
and just be you know just treat us like
I'm rushing then yeah unless it's an IRL
stream that Conor's doing yeah down down
please just stay away from him stay away
I'm horrible I'm horrible well this one
guy like already pissed off at me
because I I was running in my train and
I was literally like it literally be
pulled up and I had to go underneath the
platform get on the other side to get to
the train and I could I had headphones
in but I could hear someone shouting
after me as I'm running down these
stairs to go underneath he's like just
chasing me and then like like he like
for a good like 20 seconds and I'm
currently running and I'm not running
away from him I'm just trying to get the
[__] train yeah I gotta wait another
five minutes I miss it yeah I was
already late and I'm about to get on the
train I took up my headphones hi and he
said can I take a picture I'm like no I
gotta get on this [__] train she's
like well [__] you then no he said that
really yeah yeah I was like okay oh damn
yeah I got a guy that got off the train
to take a photo with me like he was
looking I was on the train going
somewhere and he was sitting opposite
and he just kept staring at me and I was
like I hate that and then I got off and
he got off and he's like oh my God you
get a photo so he like he got off the
whole train the train left and then he
had to wait for the next one I was like
wow that's commitment he was really nice
guy now I love chatting with him so like
that's all that matters but like the
difference after me
don't Sprint after me and don't be rude
if clearly you're in a hurry yeah I mean
I was running literally running yeah
like I feel like you just don't stop
people if they're running just feel the
only unbelievable point of that story
was you getting a train Connor yeah
man lives off taxis dude well yeah you
know I'm kind of jumped guilty of
getting too many taxis he's
single-handedly keeping the taxi
companies afloat in this country
I know I know it's bad because some yeah
absolutely my privilege is a shark
sometimes I gotta I'll get a taxi I'll
order it to my house and then I'll open
up the the name right and then I'll see
like that I ordered it from the same guy
like four times in the past oh my God
because their name will pop up and it'll
be like tanakasan is your driver today
and I'll see it four times prior they
see your private driver at this point
yeah I should have been like Tanaka man
let's just cut the [__] let's just cut
out the middle man I'll give you 20
squids
what's your what's your private number
hello
stop giving them a cup like
why are we wasting time
um well yeah yeah I I do it a lot
because also I realize that you can also
tax deduct it a lot of the time and it's
I was like all right this is very nice
in the summer absolutely [__] I will
only get the train if it is like so much
more convenient it makes more sense but
if I can avoid it in the summer I'll
just taxi I'd rather I'll just go broke
I'll just lose all my money I just don't
go out in the summer yeah that's just
impossible it's a show I I I wish people
would stop being like it can't be that
bad right I'm like no it is just not fun
I went to I was in Kyoto just for like
the day
uh in the station we only saw I didn't I
think we saw like the ratio was like
like it just is just of like of like uh
foreign looking people but it looked
like the ratio was like three to one
foreigners to Japanese people yeah it
was crazy it was all I'm like why would
you be in Kyoto in the summer so brutal
Japan in general I I it's really not fun
I've had some friends come over recently
for something and like I just can't
enjoy it it's like a fling grilled
experience when you step out there are
so many people who come around this time
as well I'm just like you could have
picked any other any other monster some
people come in next month for some
Pokemon stuff oh yeah yeah yeah it's
like why yeah why don't come here in
August that's literally the worst month
because they love Pokemon
awful awful yeah I mean like it's it's
[__] unbearable even as a Southeast
Asian for me as well
because even I don't know how it
compares to like Vietnam when you're in
Vietnam but I don't think Thailand gets
it gets pretty bad but not like this bad
I think it's just because at least the
mega City that Tokyo is obviously
Bangkok is obviously like a huge [__]
city as well but it just traps heat so
[__] yeah Vietnam was kind of like
this in the cities for sure but like if
you're in like small villages it's a
little bit better but yeah yeah that's
the problem especially in Tokyo it's
just like all the concrete just sucks on
the heat it's like Horrible no trees I
feel the heat radiator yeah yeah but
whereas if you go to like the inuka or
something it's like a couple of degrees
cooler already just because on the
ground I discovered what wet bulb
temperature was this year is that where
your skin doesn't evaporate the sweat
because humidity right yeah I think it's
something to do with a mixture of the
Heat and that can Google just to make
sure I'm not talking about my ass but
essentially like I think it's like a
certain temperature on the scale like no
amount of water or shade can help you
like it's actually just dangerous to be
outside for extended periods of time
really I think Japan is regular
it's like man you see people working in
construction you're like what the [__]
like I've got those weird fans though
they're fancy well you notice that yeah
they have the yeah like two exhausts
here and they look like Michelin men
they have like a permanent Shield
yeah but it's [__] that it's gotten to
that point where like to be outside or
even let me be a walker you have to wear
a fan suit [__] astronauts right here
yeah
it's it's kind of I really I really want
to make that for the next nonsense piece
just the [__] the fan jackets and the
summer dude you need it yeah it's [__]
I mean I just yeah it's it's absolute
suffering main takeaway don't come here
in August yeah July June July August
June's not a super terrible it's July
August July and August yeah June is also
June is mostly just like raining so it's
kind of miserable even September the
start of September Is Not Great yeah
it's pretty rough it's still bearable
though it's still bearable better better
it's the most British conversation ever
yeah over the weather
it is that why it's it's like it's all
you can think about because the moment
you leave your house you feel like
you're on a timer of like death well
yeah I just don't even in here it's
really quite hot yeah